the Chekov forest in southwest Ethiopia
is vast it covers more than 2,300 square
kilometers and is one of the country's
last remaining green belts the magical
heart of the Chekov forest is home to
unique species of birds like those that
live only here at the Shake Shack off
all the Carrera tree unique to Ethiopia
grows plentifully here the forest has a
Corazon that is specially protected and
a larger development zone this area
includes Masha the largest town in the
region home to 50,000 people and
population numbers are growing the
development zone is supposed to be used
sustainably but trees are increasingly
being cleared to make way for farming at
onavo dick bay from the forest
protection authority says there are no
easy solutions there is compromised
because you know when we protect the
forest in sustainable manner they have
to get income from that conservation
beehives offer one sustainable source of
income the Ethiopian aid organization
malcolm bought the hives with funding
from the international climate
initiative the project is helping
farmers like a Yalie LMAO him when i
ended an army no temari here thanks to
the honey that we sell we can buy
clothes for our children and books with
their schooling we can pay our taxes and
improve our homes khatta meetha shame
will stunt on only the Lula tree is on
the list of endangered species this one
stands in the garden of de quito artists
tanta a respected clan leader the
authority that he exercises plays an
important role in helping to protect the
forest anyone who cuts down a tree
without permission must pay with an ox
the Lula tree is sacred to people here
and used in prayer rituals cutting it
down would be out of the question
you wanna cut down our holy places are
destroyed and the trees felled life
can't continue without rain there'll be
no harvest it would be the beginning of
the end the people of shikahr live in
the forest and from the forest and
that's the only way to ensure it remains
protected